BEST IN THE LECOMES AROUND.
NOW RIGHT THER
HE COULD NOT KEEP IT, SO NICE TT
BACK T
BARELY OUT OF HIS REACH.
LOOKING FOR KUBALIK.
IT WAS ON THE BOARD TOAFSSON.
IF HE MOVED HIS SKATES,  HE
NEVER TAKES A STRIKE HERE.UR MI
>> Eddie: ESPECIALLY IN A THEY
SHOT IT, AND IT'S NEVER GOT
THROUGH.S ALREADY, I AM NOT
SURE IF THAT GOES ALONNES, THE T
HERE, JUMPING IN AT THE
SHOT OF THE SEASON A, MURPHY IS
TIME
HE DID, WHAT A PLAY BY BURNS PE
KNOW HOW YOU ARE DOING AND HOW
YOU ARE FEELING.
U OLD
LINEMATE RIGHT HERE.ES, HE WAS H
SOSOA COUPLE OF
YOUR LON
>> Pat: WHY HETHE PARENTS
THERE..
>> Eddie: REALLY NICE DEFENSIVE
PLAY THERE ON A THREE ON TWO
FOR THE RESTOCK, AND WENT WIDE.
HURTLING DEEP.
WATCH THIS TOUCH PASS RIGHT
THERE. HEAT ON.
>> Eddie: SOME FRESH PLAYERS ON
THE ICE FOR THE HAWKS RIGHT NON
AND TAKE IT RIGHT TO THE TO
JUST MAKE THE PASS.
JONES TRYING TO BREAK THE
HIS TEAM IN FRON.
HELD I